[Laughter]
also technically it's climate change
okay
okay so a man who said global warming be
more specific what about global warming
[Applause]
he doesn't know what the cops summit is
right so uh
ice caps cool global warming ice caps
see someone someone whispered and he was
like isn't that a sports team
global warming ice caps he knows the
buzzwords let's count to people in this
corner of the room what would you like
to rap about
vaccination cool what about vaccination
and he was uninformed
[Laughter]
come on child support child support and
vaccination yeah whatever that means
okay
um okay vaccination child support global
warming ice caps middle of the room what
would you like a wrap about
well no because he's here
one is an allergy the other's a symptom
and now let's come to the back corner
what would you like a freestyle about
english people
english people in their obsession with
tea i do hope you are indian otherwise
that was the most effective accident
if that's a white guy doing that oh my
god
okay english people in their obsession
with t so this then lovely people to
close out the show it's a freestyle
that's a wrap made up on the spot based
entirely on suggestions let's get this
oh my gosh you are the most helpful
person ever thank you so much i
appreciate that um it's a wrap about
global warming and the ice caps about
vaccination child support english people
and their obsession with tea and
allergies and sneezing and don't worry
when he was atrociously badger expecting
a privately educated middle-class white
british boy to
[Applause]
be fun nice
drop it off yeah feeling up the nice rap
turning up the heat like i'm burning
down the ice caps all the arctic flows
alameda coming down turning to water out
from the glaciers
where the global warming starts for sure
it starts to figure out how all of the
currents stop and dead never get any
warm water touching the head upon the
beach on your toes in the sand sea level
rising all of your never understand new
york in about 20 years i thought to
never buy property it's covered in water
that's the warning the global warming we
know it's gonna happen guys yeah it's a
sure thing you're like now we've got
another 50 now about
[Music]
let me tell you what to do hire a
private detective hire a little white
slu tell them to go and check out your
wife's dumpster and maybe pull used
condoms from there be like she's full of
impropriety
to see provide you
with your kids and if you get that then
i'll tell you what you did you gotta
take her to mcdonald's give him all the
happy meal they're like hey i finally
feel cool moving over here yet to send
them to school they probably gotta get
that vaccine all the right wing people
on twitter not key may be like no it's a
proven i hate it i don't want a
microchip done by bill gates an heir of
the
shouldn't be inside there who's owning
madonna and pfizer probably all of the
people i know people think the vaccines
are evil but don't worry you're not
gonna get an allergic reaction well
when i go outside
[Music]
[Applause]
in the summer when it's so green
and then the guy in the corner is
telling it he does the accent which i
can't repeat he's like why english
people love the team
[Applause]
did you enjoy the tea mom she says yes i
do so go and pillage and then we invaded
and destroyed every village
[Applause]